JESSE: WHERE IS KAMALA HARRIS?
THE VP MOSTLY MIA SINCE
AFGHANISTAN.
SHE NEVER WENT TO THE BORDER.
SHE WAS APPOINTED CHAIR OF THE
SPACE COUNCIL BUT NEVER HOSTED A
MEETING.
AND THE VIDEO SHE CREATED, SHE
HIRED CHILD ACTORS.
DO PEOPLE KNOW KAMALA HARRIS OR
KNOW WHAT SHE IS UP TO?
I MITT THE STREETS TO FIND OUT.
>> WHO IS THAT?
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS.
>> KAMALA HARRIS.
A LOVELY VICE PRESIDENT.
>> WHO IS THIS?
>> I CAN'T EVEN TELL YOU WHO IS
THAT.
JESSE: TAKE A GUESS.
>> THAT'S BILL DEBLASIO?
>> THE GOVERNOR.
HAT THAT'S HARRIS, RIGHT?
THE MAYOR.
JESSE: RIGHT.
>> NO, SHE IS THE VIET
PRESIDENT.
>> THAT LITTLE GIRL WAS ME.
JESSE: WHAT DO YOU LIKE ABOUT
KAMALA HARRIS?
>> NOTHING.
JESSE: WHAT DO YOU THINK KAMALA
HARRIS STANDS FOR?
>> HERSELF.
>> UNITY, EQUALITY.
JESSE: WHAT HAS SHE DONE TO
SUPPORT EQUALITY?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> SHE DOESN'T NECESSARILY KNOW
WHAT THE PUBLIC WANTS.
THAT KIND OF PLAYS OUT INTO AN
ADMINISTRATION THAT DOESN'T KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
JESSE: WHAT GOOD DO YOU THINK
SHE HAS DONE AS VICE PRESIDENT.
>> OBVIOUSLY NOT HAVE MUCH.
>> WHAT HAS SHE DONE FOR THE
PEOPLE?
>> THEY DONE A LOT.
>> WE DID IT, JOE.
JESSE: WHAT DO YOU THINK SHE IS
DOING WELL?
>> I JUST FEEL LIKE THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS BASICALLY
DESTROYED BLACK AND SPANISH
COMMUNITIES.
JESSE: WHAT DO YOU THINK KAMALA
HARRIS HAS DONE WELL?
>> I'M NOT SURE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT SHE HAS DONE.
I'M GIVING HER A FAIR CHANCE.
JUST LET ME KNOW WHAT'S GOING
ON.
JESSE: WHAT DO YOU THINK KAMALA
HARRIS IS HELPING JOE BIDEN
WITH?
>> I DON'T ANY SHE IS HELPING
HIM WITH ANYTHING.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT JOE BIDEN
IS DOING.
>> I THINK EVERY DAY AS PART OF
OUR JOB -- I DO DOG WALKING.
JESSE: IT'S KIND OF LIKE WHAT
KAMALA HARRIS DOES WITH JOE.
JESSE: WHAT WOULD YOU ADVICE.
>> GIVE PEOPLE 4.
>> ACRES AND A MULE.
>> ONE MILLION DOLLARS.
JESSE: IF YOU WERE KAMALA HARRIS
GIVING ADVICE TO JOE BIDEN, WHAT
WOULD YOU TELL THE PRESIDENT?
>> RESIGN, MAN.
>> TO DO WHAT IS BEST FOR THE
COUNTRY AS A WHOLE.
WHAT WILL PUSH OUR COUNTRY
FORWARD INSTEAD OF KEEPING IT
THE LAUGHINGSTOCK OF THE WORLD.
JESSE: DO YOU KNOW WHO I AM?
>> FROM TV?
HAVE WE WORKED TOGETHER?
>> THAT'S